next new or speeding car Chester
pinehill Dyson hofer is in Mexico where
the new audi q5 is being built the first
generation was very successful Audi
having sold over 1.6 million units since
2008 normally you wouldn't be keen to
change much but nevertheless the
developers gave it a reworking you might
not notice from the outside with a new
edition looking almost identical to its
predecessor the divine holds more
interested in the character of the car
and the technology inside the Audi's on
Tess help soon via The Annoying audiko
phone yet stuffed inside the q5 comes
with quite a few extras some you spot
immediately like the new features in the
interior more about that later but the
new driver assist some of which are
optional are less obvious if you're
stuck in traffic for example the q5 can
steer itself following the vehicles
ahead the car can also detect the
potential head-on collision and break if
necessary maximize lawrence's the new q5
is up to 90 kilos lighter than its
predecessor there's a choice of 30
different warning and assist systems for
those who drive a lot line hold
recommends the Quattro ultra all-wheel
drive system it decouples the front axle
from the rear activating the latter only
when needed the sensors are fast to
react pre-empting any potentially
hazardous situations before they can
arise another advantage over permanent
all-wheel drive it saves fuel
and Germany the q5 comes with a choice
of one gasoline and three diesel engines
we're testing the most powerful diesel a
two-liter unit with 140 kilowatts it
accelerates from 0 to 100 km/h and 7.8
seconds and as a top speed of 218 our
version with the top equipment line
cells in Germany from just over 48
thousand euros little has changed in the
exterior design compared to rival models
the q5 looks very conservative and
certainly doesn't stand out from the
crowd but the new LED headlights do add
a little charisma the roofline slopes
gently at the rear and COO paid like
style the roof edge spoiler and skid
plate give the q5 a subtly sporty look
but overall the outer design is less
than exciting
cuz they kick know about what's really
new says vine hood is the air suspension
something that only Daimler offers in
this class otherwise it ensures a very
comfortable ride and also makes the q5
quite sporty by adjusting the body
height if you want to get moving the q5
can crouch down low on the road but if
you go off-road and gives you a lot more
ground clearance it costs an additional
two thousand euros a thousand less than
Daimler's equivalent in tolleson lumia
the audi drive select feature adjust the
ground clearance to driving conditions
an all road mode that's two and a half
centimeters above the normal level lift
off-road mode offers a further two
centimetres for negotiating especially
uneven terrain dynamic mode
significantly reduces the ground
clearance increasing stability and
improving the aerodynamics in anniston
oy i note says inside the cab of the new
audi q5 has once again set standards and
workmanship it finally includes Audi's
virtual cockpit with a 12 point 3 inch
display can be set up as you want
there's no touchscreen but you do have a
touchpad on the center console that at
least has the advantage that you don't
leave any greasy finger marks on the
screen of your GPS an important detail
too many design oriented Audi customers
in design orientation OD nuts up
audi says the interior is designed to be
a feel-good lounge and thanks to the
increased space for all passengers you
can certainly spread out the fully
digital cockpit and MMI entertainment
system are the obvious highlights both
of these are optional however and
together costs an additional three
thousand three hundred fifty euros the
seats have a completely new design and
way less thanks to reinforced steel in
the base the front seats can be fitted
with a massage function if desired via
noise on news I know thanks if a car is
really new it should look different but
that's his only criticism the q5 offers
everything the q7 has but is more
compact more manageable and a little
cheaper it's built in Mexico but the
engineering is still made in Germany the
new q5 is due to hit dealers in early
2017 Audi's key target markets here are
the US China and Europe the basic
version of the q5 costs around 45
thousand euros in Germany
[Music]